immer zwei tage da und dann mal wieder
ein tag urlaub ist auch okay finde ich
mein man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts und
schon ist sie mal rein philosophie vier
deutsch viel englisch für etwas gehabt
und jetzt willkommen bahnen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut
und ja ich muss sagen es ist okay ihr
habt mich überzeugt ist gut lassen sich
damit jetzt bisschen ruhe also muss auch
das war folgendermaßen ich habe ja
damals so neues intro gesucht weil ich
meine es halt schon so lange hat und
wirklich mal neues wollte und dieses
eine intro was sich jetzt einen letzten
videos öfter mal drin hatte ich fand das
wirklich so genial und ich fand das so
witzig und ich habe ich gehofft dass ihr
das auch cool findet weil ich mein so
was hat kein anderer youtuber so ein
intro nur irgendwie fand ihr tier es
jetzt nicht so gut beziehungsweise
überhaupt nicht gut gruselig verstörend
psychisch krank de abonniert wegen beim
intro und am anfang dachte ich wirklich
noch alex kommen die gewöhnen sich schon
daran das dauert jetzt vielleicht ein
zwei monate aber dann ist das ein cooles
intro und jeder feiert das nur ihr
findet es immer noch psychisch krank
verstörend komplett dumm hässlich ich
sehe aus dem clown und deswegen habe ich
jetzt gesagt gut wenn ich raus gibt es
halt kein android ich hoffe ihr seid
jetzt zufrieden
[Musik]
egal warum sollte ein logischer weise
gar nicht gehen ich habe mich sehr
gefreut das letzte zeugnis video ist er
extrem gut angekommen dankeschön und ihr
habt mir seitdem wirklich gefühl wieder
500 zeugnisse geschickt also bei mir ist
alles voll mit zeugnissen mein
e-mail-postfach corp oder wie das heißt
deswegen wenn ihr auch mal mit eurem
zeugnis sind meine ich das video wollte
gerne mal instagram profil hat so heiß
ich da folgt mir da und schickt mir
gerne zeugnis tue und ich glaube wir
dass der mann es sei natürlich hab keine
lust mehr auf neues video deswegen heute
8000 likes und dann machen wir das
nächste video darüber so dadurch auch
gar nicht mehr lange lagern ich würde
sagen fangen sofort an ich habe mir
einige zeugnisse rausgesucht die
wirklich heute nicht ganz so gut sind
also heute haben wir wirklich kein brain
dabei ich weiß oder ein vielleicht keine
ahnung ja ich meine wunderschöne natur
wieder rauskramen und mal sehen was war
so finden wir fangen an mit dem ersten
täglich so das erste zeugen das kommt
von schild kein name beide es zensiert
worden ja wir schauen wir genauer hin
verhaltene zwei mitarbeiter zwei man
sich erstmal auch das fängt ja gut an
ist bestimmt ein guter schüler
wir gehen weiter zu den fächern und zwar
haben wir hier den deutschen 4 in
englischen 4 in volks- und
betriebswirtschaftslehre auch nur vier
kann aber passieren jetzt rund 5 in
mathe eine vielen geschichte eine drei
oder fünf musik dazu eine für spanisch
eine 5 in privates vermögensmanagement
eine 5 -15 wie vor uneins und den rest
obwohl das war jetzt gut informatik 3
und sport zwei kurze frage wenn du
überall 5 und hass wie kann man denn
bitte in mitarbeitende 2 bekommen
so ich weiß dass ich in welche klasse du
bist aber du bist ja auch ein gymnasium
deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus
dass du hoffentlich nicht in der siebten
klasse ist sondern vielleicht schon
jahrzehnte die ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen hinsetzt weil ich glaube so wie
das auf keinen fall was mit der
versetzung also cia lockern durchschnitt
von 4 kommend was wenn nicht sogar 4,5
würdig martin kopp das leben geht weiter
ja geil so willkommen zum nächsten
zeugnis und das ist von der lieben
charlotte charlotte geht in die klasse r
us here de etc
charlotte das ist es ja ganz normaler
klassen name kennt jeder ich war damals
auch in der us5 de.com zvg und dann guck
mal was sie charlotte dann so geleistet
hat geht es also das sind punkte oder
was nicht also was zeugnis verstehe ich
wirklich nicht charlotte hat keine noten
charlotte hat 10 bis 0 biologie sechs
punkte charlotte hat zu beginn fleißig
mitgearbeitet die note im test spiegelt
nicht ihr können wieder nicht die
motivation verlieren charlotte ja also
charlotte ach so vielleicht ist das ein
waldorf zurück
das kann nicht nur in charlotte mach
weiter so nicht die motivation verlieren
wenn der test einmal nicht so gut läuft
sind diesmal wird's besser chemie neun
punkte bleibt er 28 punkte gutgemacht
charlotte was ist das habe ich echt noch
nie gesehen schreibt wendy kommentare
woher glauben wir kommt charlotte
erdmann der achteinhalb punkte
informatik neuen punkte brache 1 sprache
zwei blablabla am mathe acht anhalt für
sechs acht und so weiter was ich echt
gut aus charlotte ist ja alles im oberen
bereich mathe mitarbeit steht den
mitarbeitern und trifft es gut du bist
meist aufmerksam und aktiv bei der sache
auch schriftlich kannst du dein wissen
angemessen da liegen ja da kann man
eigentlich nicht groß drum äckern die
charlotte macht ihren job echt gut
wie gesagt noch weiter so nicht die
motivation verlieren wir deine
biologielehrerin
das sehe ich genauso und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit wenigstens mit sohn das
ist das einzige zeug wie charlotte aber
auch gut aber das ist heute das einzige
zeugnis was wirklich sensationelles wir
haben hier
ich weiß nicht von wem es ist hat er
abgeschnitten versäumte stunden fünf
davon natürlich natürlich 0 deutsch ein
sprachrohr eines lesen eines recht
schnell und gut sachunterricht 1 matte 1
englisch und musik als kunst 1 rallye 1
sport1 simon simon ist es simon hat
erfolgreich an der pc ag und an der
radfahrausbildung teil schlimm wie man
das finde ich richtig gut dass du dich
was das radfahren an jetzt richtig ins
zeug
da wird ja immer gut auf das fahrrad
auch wirklich verkehrstauglich ist ist
licht vorne und hinten hast du
reflektoren an den reifen ist das schutz
welche noch in ordnung und so weiter und
dann steht der erfolgreichen
radfahrausbildung natürlich auch nichts
weniger simon hat das sportabzeichen in
gold error und jemand hat sich im ersten
halbjahr im rahmen der badi ag für
schüler engagiert simon du bist hammer
und dann auch noch so ein gutes zeugnis
da sind die eltern bestimmt stolz so wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten zeugnis
und das kommt von raffael und raphael ja
ja ich möchte klasse also hier man sich
jetzt wirklich sagen das ist das
schlechteste zeugnis dass ich in meinem
ganzen leben gesehen habe praktische
philosophie sechs deutsch englisch und
mathe 66 physik 645 technik selbst sport
4d wenigstens den sportlern noch
normalerweise ich kenne so viele die
auch ein extrem schlechtes zeugnis haben
aber sport war dann wenigstens immer
zwei oder sogar 1 naturwissenschaften 6
das ist ja das ist ja hier was machst du
denn und raphael var 121 stunden nicht
da davon unentschuldigt 100 stunden
aber ich glaube da muss ich mal ein
ernstes wörtchen mitgeredet also so geht
es nicht weiter
angaben zum außerunterrichtlichen
engagement keine ich meine da hat sich
doch wenigstens mal ein bisschen
engagiert
naja das ist den kopf traf er macht
weiter nächstes schuljahr sieht das
schon wieder ganz anders aber du musst
halt nun mal kommen
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
zeugnis das wird mir über amsterdam
erstickt und da wurde auch direkt nette
text runter geschrieben und zwar kurz
eingeblendet nach dem zeugnis bin ich
von der schule geflogen
deswegen auch abgangszeugnis ich mache
jetzt mein fachabitur und seitdem läuft
die schule viel besser ab abitur finde
ich auch vollkommen in ordnung ich mein
fachabitur ist ja auch das ist heute
abitur drin weiß ich immer schlauer an
aber jetzt schauen wir uns erstmal ein
zeugnis an so ihr abgangszeugnis deutsch
5+ englisch viel - französisch 5+
geschichte 4 - geografie 4 - matte vom
fluss mathematik 5 - her erst mit zwei
mathe oder physik chemie 4+ view 4 -
bildende kunst 4 sport plus ist erst ein
kandidat über als schlecht außer den
sport das hat dann leider nicht zur
versetzung gereicht aber so lang ist
jetzt gut wie das ja alles cool also
viel glück bei dem fachabi streng dich
an und dann wird das was so in jetzt zum
schluss kommen wir zum absoluten mörder
zeugnis hier wird einiges zensiert aber
wir fangen einfach mal an es geht um die
achte klasse und wir befinden uns auf
einem zweiten halbjahr der versetzung
ich glaube das war nix da muss man
nochmal eine kleine ehrenrunde eingelegt
werden und die achte klasse kann man
natürlich noch mal machen das ja gar
kein problem was sich hier als erstes
übertrieben geschockt hat versäumte
stunden 289 an dieser frage ich mich
ganz ehrlich warst du überhaupt da ich
meine ich rechne das jetzt einfach mal
kurz aus ich sag mal so achte klasse da
geht man jeden tag ungefähr sechs
stunden schule
das heißt jan 30 stunden pro woche und
ein halbjahr besteht immer ungefähr
glaube ich aus 24 wochen ich weiß es
nicht ganz genau wer recht ist einfach
mal mal 24 gleich 720 okay ja gut was
schon zur hälfte daher gut sogar
bisschen mehr als die hälfte also kann
man sich so vorstellen immer zwei tage
da und dann mal wieder ein tag urlaub
ist auch okay finde ich mein man gönnt
sich ja sonst nichts von mir schon ist
sie mal rein philosophie vier deutsch
vier englisch 5 kunst vier geschichte
405 politik für mathematik fünf biologie
565 sport
was da war also da frage ich mich jetzt
echt gerade wie das geht weil ich meine
sechs zu bekommen muss ja wirklich nie
da gewesen sein
bei uns gab es immer die die karten dann
halt wenigstens und hatten dann halt
irgendwann nachlässt weil sie wussten
hatten oder so und mussten dann nie
mitmachen aber hatten dann am ende
wenigstens eine vier minus weil sie ab
und zwar was gesagt haben oder die
matten aufgebaut haben durchschnitt von
ebenfalls an die 50 schwimmer typen sind
durchschnitt von 4,7 oder so das war
wohl nix mit der achten klasse aber ist
ja klar so 289 versagen bestanden das
kann natürlich auch blöde gründe haben
irgendeine krankheit oder so deswegen
hoffe du wirst schnell wieder fit falls
du nicht die ganze zeit schwänzt und
dann sieht das nächstes jahr schon
wieder ganz anders aus das sage ich
irgendwie in jedem video dreimal
also leute das was mit dem video schauen
was hat euch gefallen kriegt mir bei
instagram einfach weitere zeugnis von
euch zu dass nur noch oben dabei 8000
gleich gibt's die nächste folge und wir
sehen uns wieder keine ahnung